sur la maison de ma grand-mère à Taïwan
quelle trace laisse un lieu dans notre
mémoire quel souvenir déclenche-t-il
Sophie fait partie de ses élèves du
lycée Corneille de La Celle-Saint-Cloud
a participé à un travail autour des
souvenirs j'aime pas trop parler des
choses personnelles et du coup là c'est
quand même une opportunité de le faire
et au lycée on s'attend pas forcément à
parler à quelque chose qui nous touche
de si près et du coup je trouvais ça
intéressant et puis aussi c'est vrai que
les profs ils nous ont quand même laissé
une assez grande liberté une vingtaine
d'élèves a répondu à la proposition de
plusieurs professeurs de l'établissement
récit poème interview la mémoire se
transmettra dans différents formats j'ai
tout de suite pensé à mon site de danse
et du coup je me suis dit ce serait
formidable que moi j'arrive à faire
transmettre des émotions par rapport à
ce que j'adore faire c'est un défi oui
parce que c'est compliqué d'écrire mais
en même temps vu que j'adore le sujet et
que j'aime bien aussi écrire tout ce qui
est français tout ça les rédactions
c'est toujours quelque chose qui m'a plu
la mémoire autour de la géographie et le
deuxième volet d'un projet du lycée
Corneille en 2021 2022 les élèves
volontaires ont réfléchi à la mémoire
historique pour faire naître un livre
j'ai pu interviewer mon grand-père et du
coup ça m'a donné une occasion de
discuter avec lui et j'ai adoré je l'ai
interviewé sur la garde d'Algérie parce
qu'il a eu une expérience là-bas en tant
que soldat français et du coup j'ai eu
un point de vue de cette guerre et j'ai
trouvé ça trop bien de pouvoir partager
ces moments avec lui parce que nous
souhaitions c'est d'une part
relatée rapportée des histoires arrivées
à des membres de la famille mais qui
s'en sert dans la grande Histoire donc
on a des histoires au moment de la
guerre au moment de la décolonisation
pour l'élève lui-même
cela a permis de d'intensifier le lien
intergénérationnel on a des témoignages
extrêmement touchants très émouvant un
ouvrage destiné alors cercle familial et
amical une dizaine de professeurs
d'histoire-géographie de langue de
philosophie et de lettres accompagnent
les élèves un nouveau livre verra le
jour en 2023